Hi, my name is Ronit
Langer, and I'm
a junior studying electrical
engineering and computer
science, and I'm really
interested in problems
that exist at the boundary of
computer science and biology.
One of the really
pressing problems
that I'd like to
address in my research
is the growing opioid crisis
and the effect that it's
having on our first responders.
When a first responder
comes onto a scene,
they're not sure
what's in the air.
And the problem is, is that
more powerful opioids, when
they're aerosolized, could
be potentially lethal.
And so what we want to do is
create a biological sensor
that's able to tell the first
responders whether or not
those opioids are
present in the air.
The problem is, is that the
current biological sensor we
have available to us is the
natural mu opioid receptor that
lives in our brain.
But the mu opioid
receptor actually
binds promiscuously to
all sorts of opioids,
leading to the opioid
crisis in the first place.
And so what we want to do, is
to take this mu opioid receptor,
and mutate it in such a way
that it binds very specifically
to powerful opioids.
The problem is, in
protein engineering,
in general, is that we don't
have a good understanding
of the relationship between
sequence, structure,
and function of a protein.
Also, the possible
sequence space
that exists when you
have 20 amino acids
is so much larger than the
observed amino acid space
that we see in nature.
And so what we want
to do in this project
is to be able to take
the mu opioid receptor,
and mutate it in silica--
meaning in, on the
computer, and then
build it in vivo, and
test it in living cells,
such that we can
speed up this process
and create more powerful
protein sensors.
And so the way we do this is
we curate a large training
set of very similar proteins
to the mu opioid receptor,
and we test to see how
different mutations affect them
in living proteins.
And then we use that to train
a machine learning algorithm,
which can then recommend
better sequences for us
moving forward.
And then we go and we test
those sequences in cells.
And then this process iterates
until we get to the desired
functionality of our protein.
And so once we've done this
for the mu opioid receptor,
we can take this
technology and extend it
to many other problems
that exist in the protein
engineering space.